على كل حال سال الناس بالاردن لو حصلت على
يوم راحه اضافي في اسبوعك كيف يمكن ان
تستفيد منه نتابع
[موسيقى]
ممكن اقضي انه ثلثين للنهار نوم والثلث
بضل ممكن اروح اطمن على الحجه كوني متجوز
جديد وبعدت عنها من خمسه اشهر كان في احلى
من الواحد يرتاح يكون فيه له راح اسبوعية
ممكن يا اما بستغل افراحه في الدار يا اما
بطلع مع واحد من اصدقائي من واحد من
اصحابي بنطلع من شم هوا وبنروح بنيجي ناخذ
اليوم زاهر بالمحبه بالعفويه
[موسيقى]
يعني بصراحه اول شيء بفكر فيه اني انام في
زياده بعدين اذا في اكتيف مع اصحابي او
اشي ممكن اطلع بحس انه اول شيء راح اخطط
لطلعه اني اطلع مع اصحابي انبسط باليوم
وبعمل شويه اكتفيتيز بس راح استفيد منه
بالنوم راح انام
واذا كان بالصيف بطلع وعادي بس بالشتاء
بنام برد بسحب برد بنام
[موسيقى]
عطله
خطيبتي ساعه زمن ساعتين زمان
وما كان عندي وقت فهيك يعني اي واحد يتمنى
انه يكون في عنده يوم راحه ولكن لكل عمر
في طريقه معينه للراحه بمعنى انه لما كل
واحد فوق الستين سنه بحب الهدوء بحب اذا
كان في عنده احفاد يقعد معهم فهمت ويغير
جو
[موسيقى]